145 نائبا من اصل 201
سيشكلون برلمان تونس الجديد بعد استكمال
الاستحقاق التشريعي الاول منذ اعلان
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في البلاد على ان
يتم ذلك طبقا للاجراءات القضائيه
والقانونيه
سجلنا قيام تصويت
الفئنين ناخذ تونسي توجهه الى صناديع يوم
الانتخابات التشريعيه وما حفا بها من ظروف
سياسيه الا ان منظمات المجتمع المدني
المحليه والدوليه القارات بانها كانت
مزيحه
جدا خاصه للانتخابات
لم يتجاوزوا ما بين خمسه وسته في المئه من
الجسم الانتخابي وفور اعلان النتائج خرجت
قوى المعارضه فيما عدى استثمارا سياسيا
لتطالب الرئيس سعيد بالتنحي او على الاقل
بادخال تعديلات سياسيه كبيره على برنامجه
لا يتاخر الرد من سعيد ليعلن نهايه
المنظومه القديمه ملوحا بالمحاسبه
تونس
للتونسيين والتونسيات
وليست للضيعه هي يرتع فيها من يشاء كما
يشاء
رؤساءتحمل هؤلاء مسؤوليه خيانتهم العظمى
لتونس
2019 اغلق نهائيا وان السيد راشد الغنوشي
لم يعد بتلك الحصانه التي يحظى بها كرئيس
برلمان ليس داخليا فقد حسم الامر ولكن
خارجيا
وينتظر هنا عقاد البرلماني الجديد منتصف
شهر مارس اذان المقبل على اقصى تقدير وعلى
راسي اولوياته الملفات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
وبعدما بحث صناديق الاقتراعي باسرارها
وتوضحت ملامح البرلمان الجديد تتوجه
الانظار نحو مالات الازمه المركبه وافاق
حلها مع تمدرس كل طرف بموقفه بما يبقي
الوضع مفتوحا على اكثر من احتمال وليد
عبدالله العربيه
تونس